- Progress in the sexual
abuse case against
Prince Andrew of the Royal Family.
As you may know, Virginia Giuffre
has accused Prince Andrew
of abusing her as a minor
in connection with Jeffrey Epstein.
So she has been trying to personally serve
Prince Andrew with the
lawsuit papers so that
she can continue in her
lawsuit in New York.
And not surprisingly,
Prince Andrew has been dodging service.
You probably know that
when you file a lawsuit,
you need to usually personally
hand the service papers
to the defendant before you
can begin the lawsuit itself.
And sometimes it's really
hard to serve people,
especially if they are evading service.
In this particular case,
the court granted Giuffre's motion
for what's called alternative service,
saying that she had tried
everything to serve this guy,
but he's not making himself available.
He almost certainly has
knowledge of this lawsuit,
so alternative means can be used.
But in a twist, basically the day after,
Giuffre was able to
personally serve the Prince
at a private club in the UK.
So, it looks like he's going
to be a part of this lawsuit
and we will see them in court.